all right looks like we're now live for
our June AMA had to think about what
month it was for just a minute
um so we've already got some good
questions lined up Mark says hi to
everybody hope you're doing well for me
it's been a week of a lot of medical
appointments and so I'm kind of tired
from all of that hitting the dentist the
audiologist deep tissue massage various
other stuff but I'm ready for the AMA
and we kick off with a great question
from Galen what is a topic you wish that
Plato had written a dialogue on
something we could have benefited from
him kicking around
and so you know there's there's like a I
guess a general answer that we can give
for that and then a more like specific
what I personally would like I think
when it comes to these older
philosophers particularly
in the early years of Western philosophy
where we see really interesting topics
coming up you know 100 200 300 years
later
we kind of wish that like with Plato or
Aristotle maybe they would have taken on
more questions but perhaps they weren't
adequately formulated at the time so you
know with both Plato and Aristotle we
could talk about the questions of you
know freedom and determinism you know uh
which are taken up later on by
epicureans uh later aristotelians like
Alexander of aphrodisius stoics and we
get really interesting discussions of
that and it could have been cool to have
like you know a dialogue about that and
it could have been framed at the time in
terms of as Aristotle does to some
degree you know when we are virtuous is
that because the gods helped us out is
that because
um you know it's just random or
something like that and Plato could have
written a dialogue about that but he
didn't and I think you know we we do
have a dial blog about the cosmology of
the universe as we see it and we have
some others that you know give us some
interesting ideas like the phaedris
um but it could have been cool to have a
bit more
um
maybe some more discussions of some of
the virtues
um that don't see you know that that are
as we say operatic
um that would have been kind of nice
um
so I you know and I think personally one
of the things that always
raises issues for my students it's the
smart students who eventually get to the
point where the like wait a second Plato
um thinking about you know the nature of
the Soul as that which is able to
apprehend the platonic forms but which
is not itself a form but it is also
Immortal let's see if I can clean up
this lens a little bit there we go
um
I mean we do have a dialogue that's
entitled on the soul the Fado but it it
it's more about the immortality of the
Soul
not as much about the soul and how it
works in terms of
apprehending things we've got to kind of
piece together a composite picture
so
um
I don't know uh what will will uh
necessarily
find for that so that's that's a great
question and I think we could ask
similar questions about like what would
we have liked for Aristotle to have
approached uh given the fact that we've
lost some of the Aristotelian texts um
and we can say this with a lot of
philosophers thinking about later issues
or problems that remain unresolved
within their
their own works so great question uh
lapse nine Continuum what's up with
Fraga and Russell being so enamored with
set theory at the turn of the 20th
century was it just their attempt to
understand abstract objects I don't
think it was
um just about that so and you're right
there is it's not just Fraga and Russell
it's a lot of other people as well
there's this tendency to think that we
can
turn philosophy into a rigorous science
by mathematizing it or logicizing it and
there was actually this thing that we
call the logicist project that Russell
was part of and you know we could we
could view it as sort of a loose
Association
um rather than like you know a research
program that people had signed on for
and and I think that this is
um
you know as part of a dream that goes
back a long ways
um Descartes you know
leibniz they're people that place
incredible emphasis on mathematics and
the notion that we could like understand
everything in a quasi-mathematical way
um and you know Russell is influenced by
that notion coming from leibniz
um I suppose we could say it goes back
further as well
but you know it's it's interesting too
as a historical side note to see that
they tried to do this and then they
discovered that there's
limits to it you know gurudo's in
completeness theorem was a big kick in
the pants for everybody committed to
that but they also realize there's other
limits as well there's paradoxes that
arise there's other problems you know
explaining just what the infinite is or
how many numbers there are uh a la
Cantor these are these are some
interesting issues
all right
um
let's see
Hillel says uh who's your favorite
philosopher I don't have a favorite
philosopher any more than I have a
favorite band I have people that are
sort of in the upper tier and sometimes
they go in and they go out but I quit
having favorites probably decades ago I
just have people that I like to keep
going back to you know you can tell who
those are in part I think by
how many videos I've done on them you
know you can tell Aristotle is very
important to me because I've done at
this point I think over 200 different
videos on the guy uh likewise you know
the stoics or Plato or Descartes or you
know even even philosophers I disagree
with but I find fascinating like David
Hume
so all right said what are your thoughts
on maybe making a series on Marx or some
other prominent philosopher Economist I
already did a series on Marx you'll find
it in the World Views and values uh
sequence that I did back in
2013 maybe
um I did it for a class that was called
World Views and values that I taught at
Marist College and I shot some videos on
alienated labor and the Communist
Manifesto so already already happened
um
all right said what's an accessible
introductory book on being in time I'm
trying to get into Heidegger's
philosophy I wouldn't know because I
don't really read introductory books I
create my own resources for my students
so I am not a I'm never a good person
really to ask about secondary literature
or introductory literature unless I've
been researching that sort of thing and
you know I mean I think you just read
being in time and you see where you can
you can uh
make out in it uh useless projects have
you read any of Jacqueline Khan's works
I would suggest Google Gregory Sadler uh
Jacques Lacon and you'll see whether I
have in fact uh read any of his works
the answer is yes and I've written on
his works and presents it on his works
and was actually in a uh faculty seminar
with Alistair McIntyre years and years
ago that had to do with uh rational
Choice Theory Aristotle and St Thomas
and Freud and lacasse so
um yeah I do know a bit about him uh
what are my thoughts on his work I think
that lacan is uh useful and valuable in
some respects you don't have to buy into
everything that the guy says or become a
lacanian as a matter of fact I would
suggest not doing that and laca himself
as a vain a person as he was would
probably reject many of the supposed
onions of the present day that identify
as such and think he has the answers to
everything because he's always pointing
back at hey I don't have the answers
Freud has the answers Freud properly
understood
um
you know he uh
I think that that laca unduly made his
prose difficult to understand
um and I I consider that to be kind of a
moral failing
um you know he's kind of a show-off
um and you know makes it more difficult
to read his stuff than it needs to be
right
so all right let's see uh
Massacre where do you think Marlo Ponte
fell short at least for your taste in
philosophy it is visible in The
Invisible or phenomenology of perception
um I you know I don't think that
marilloponte necessarily fell short
that's probably not the way I would put
it he's got you know all these different
phenomenologists are doing their
different things
and I focus Less on what they didn't do
that maybe somebody else managed to do
and more on what they did do what
contributions did they make because I
think it's and this is a broader topic I
think it's kind of silly to expect that
any one thinker is going to provide you
with everything that you need you know
and this is a bit of a side topic but
all these people are like we need to
complete the system of German idealism
well there's no system to begin with of
German idealism there's systems and why
the hell would you need to complete it
why isn't it good enough you know for
what it does I mean think about uh you
know different other tools that you use
or domains of knowledge do you demand
that they do every single possible thing
um I don't you know I think that
marilopanti is cool because he you know
in the phenomenology of perception he's
got this notion of normal
perception what we typically go through
as being an overlay or interplay of all
these different domains where things can
go go wrong you know sometimes through
brain injury or sometimes through
psychological trauma or stuff like that
and then he analyzes each of them in
turn and if he was around today he'd
probably be talking about what goes on
you know through the internet and
um he'd be talking about sexuality and
other interesting ways than he did at
the time and he probably would be
incorporating some stuff about language
that we've learned
um since you know the 1930s and 40s so
all right
um
a lot of questions piling up here
uh Ben what's something you've learned
from one of your students that really
stuck with you
uh that's a good question you know I
actually answered a quora question about
that a long time ago about an argument
that I got into like in my first week of
class teaching at Indiana State Prison
with one of my students
um you know I guess you know when I talk
with my students and and this doesn't
happen so much in the class sessions
although sometimes it happens
um but more like before class and after
class I
I find out that a lot of my peers in
Academia and specifically in philosophy
despite their you know Declarations of
being concerned with Justice or fairness
or being a good person are often
teaching in such ways that are not not
doing good for their students you know
um you know great example of this is do
you accept late work and if you do do
you like get on your students case about
it and like use it as an opportunity to
drill into their heads that they're
nothing and you're the great Professor
or do you have a more like elastic uh
approach to it where you're like listen
you know life happens uh we're always in
crisis uh I want you to get the work
done because it's important to actually
do the work because it's not just make
work but it's there to like teach you
something
um I'll let you hand stuff in late and I
you know either will or won't give you a
penalty usually I don't give my students
penalties
as a matter of fact I haven't since
since covid began
um although I tell them you know there's
there's a chance that you'll lose some
points on this
um you know the students will tell me
what the other professors are doing and
I'm often not shocked but and not
dismayed but a little bit disappointed
in what goes on and I think that part of
that is you know we have a conversation
about the point of taking classes and
the point of higher education and and
what it's supposed to be giving students
you know
uh Shania says I'm concerned about the
status of philosophy in the 21st century
how it's taught in the academy what its
function is and our technological age
well I mean you're in luck because you
don't have to be concerned about the
status of philosophy because there is no
one single thing called philosophy and
it doesn't have one single status
because there is no single academy uh
here in the United States you know if
we're just talking about
philosophy there's well over 2 000
different institutions
accredited institutions where you can
study philosophy and they're not all
approaching it in the same way you know
um it philosophy doesn't have a function
in our technological age philosophy has
many functions in our technological age
so I think the way of framing it there
may be part of what is producing these
concerns but these these concerns
are better understood when we think
about like this application of
philosophy or how philosophy is being
done over here or in these types of
schools or things like that
all right
um Abraham says while reading philosophy
books how do you suggest making notes
for optimal recall and revisit uh Mark
and book or document notes there is no
right answer to that because there's no
right way to do it it it you need to
figure out for you what works for you I
don't take a lot of notes
um with a few exceptions
um and I certainly don't take like
extensive notes every once in a while I
might underline something or put a
little bit of marginalia but you know
sometimes I come back and I'm like why
did I underline that instead of this
over here you know
other people benefit very heavily by
like color coding and putting Post-it
notes in their their books and stuff
like that there is no one single best or
right approach I did a
uh Sadler's quick takes video about this
whole you know concern with the best or
the concern with how you you ought to do
things
I guess you could say that when it comes
to these sorts of matters I'm what we
call a pluralist I think that there's
many different adequate and legitimate
ways to go about studying and taking
notes and things like that
all right
um lapse nine continuum
another clarificatory question what's
the upshot of Heidegger's analysis of
worldhood I know it's meant to be more
than a mere description of The Human
Condition how does it fit into the
ontology there is no the ontology and
Heidegger there's all sorts of
ontologies plural and Heidegger's ideas
are kind of developing over time I
always had trouble seeing the big
picture in Heidegger
um and I would say you know we are
always within a world right that's part
of what it is as you mentioned uh more
than a description of the human
condition but it is it's not just a
description of The Human Condition it's
a analysis of what it is to to exist as
a human being that is for Heidegger a
being that can question being and beings
something that's self-aware something
that's aware of its environment aware of
its finitude and limitations and you
know the interesting thing is you can
can't see the world all you can see are
models of it like looking you know for
example at a globe right and you look at
that and you realize the total
inadequacy of that model right and the
fact that you could you could never like
take something like that in even if you
were like up in a space station looking
down because you're going to see natural
phenomena but you're not going to see
the borders that constitute like
political uh uh divisions which are you
know that's part of the human human
condition as well right so I don't I
don't have much more to say I think
about about that
um other than you know one of the I
think one of the great things that
Heidegger does realize is we're always
whatever perspective we're gonna have
it's going to be within something that
is globalized
and
um we're never able to take in more than
a bit of it at a time and so we're
always projecting what he calls Horizons
and this is just a phenomenological term
out there about it
all right
um
coopstar says I don't remember which
video but you briefly touched on reading
Nick of McCain ethics as a
phenomenological work can you elaborate
on it a better Point me if you've done
work on it no it's just something that I
say every once in a while and I don't
say that it's a phenomenological work
what I say is that what Aristotle is
doing is carrying out a phenomenology of
moral life within the ethical political
works I'm not talking about the
metaphysics I'm not talking about the
Optical works I'm just talking about
everything from the two ethics through
the politics rhetoric parts of the
topics you know and Poetics and stuff
like that and what I mean by that is
that and this is not a new thing that I
came up with I mean gotimer says stuff
like this Heidegger says stuff like this
about at least rhetoric book two you
know which he calls a hermeneutic of
everydayness
um I mean that Aristotle is doing the
kinds of things that later on we call
and recognize as phenomenological in
their approach to things namely we act
you know people will be like Aristotle
is an empiricist as opposed to Plato
who's the idealist and whenever I hear
that I just kind of zone out because I
know the person has just imbibed some uh
half-rate you know uh glosses and
doesn't really know what they're talking
about because Aristotle isn't an
empiricist in the sense that like lock
or Hume or even William James later on
whether it was Radical empiricist is
he's somebody who thinks that you
actually need to look at the world and
things in it and Plato did by the way
too
um and then you you know you observe and
describe and try to carry out as best as
you can distinctions between things and
say Here's you know something that looks
like Essences and you you know that's
that's doing phenomenology in a very
broad sense so
all right uh Shania what's your opinion
on myth and its relation to philosophy I
don't have any opinions on like myth and
philosophy because myth names many
things and philosophy names many things
so there are many different
relationships between them
um sand do you have you practiced
meditation any thoughts on its
usefulness it can be useful for some
people uh other people there's less
usefulness
um there's many many different kinds of
meditation there's no such thing as
meditation per se there's just
meditation uh you know taught by
different groups and schools and
movements and stuff like that and uh can
be done you know in in a lot of
different traditions
um I've done some sure I'm not a big
meditator
um maybe that's you know because of
temperament or you know my uh inability
to stay focused quite as quite as easily
I think it's one of those things that if
it helps you great if not there's so
many other cool things you can be doing
instead
um all right snoot do you have a
preferred Camp of philosophy
to engage in Continental or analytic so
these are not camps these are complex
Traditions with that go back now more
than 100 years and include
you know hundreds of important authors
um
I think it's important to avoid the
tendency to want to associate in camps
or teams or any of this sort of stuff
that's that's a unserious approach to a
serious uh matter
um instead what you want to be thinking
of is well what is analytic philosophy
what is Continental philosophy you'll
notice too if you actually Google that
I've got like an entire talk about that
and you can find the transcripts to that
in my my medium and I you know you'll
know that I think that analytic and
Continental philosophy there is no such
thing as Continental philosophy it's too
too wide of a range of stuff and we'll
talk about that in a minute but even if
we did have like two big things analytic
and Continental those are two tiny
little things within the scope of
philosophy we also have history of
philosophy we also have philosophy as a
way of life we have classical American
philosophy we have radical philosophy
which includes all sorts of things that
don't neatly fit into Continental or
analytic but sometimes overlap with them
that's all within Western philosophy and
then you know we have non-western
philosophy so there's an entire Chinese
Cultural sphere that includes you know
Vietnam all the way up to Korea there is
the entire Indian subcontinent right
there's the entire Islamic world and
those fit neatly into this Continental
versus analytic thing they do not as a
matter of fact each of them is so
complex and Rich that you could spend
your entire lifetime just studying one
of those and find many other divisions
within philosophy as a result now I said
that Continental philosophy is not
really a unified thing and if you if you
know anything about Continental
philosophy you can see that quite easily
when you look at you know anthologies
they have to divide it into different
movements and groups so you know we have
the phenomenological movement which
intersects and overlaps with the
structuralism and post-structuralism
which could include Freudian you know
Freudian approaches or maybe not uh we
have
um the uh you know let's call it the
dialectical approach that includes
everything from like you know ficta and
Hegel and shelling all the way through
marks and then we have these interesting
outliers like the great hermeneutics of
Suspicion as rakura calls it including
Nietzsche also including Marx and Freud
and that's only a tiny bit of the
picture because there's so much other
European philosophy that is technically
speaking Continental but hasn't gotten
the attention over here you know I was
just in an interesting Twitter
conversation yesterday
where somebody brought up here at Dole
you know known for philosophy as a way
of life he didn't make that up there's
all sorts of people in his time
including people he studied with like
ATI Angel Sol uh who all you know we
could also bring in Jacques Martin and
you know Maurice blownell talking about
this that are talking about philosophy
as a way of life long before Ado but who
reads them right people like me but not
not too many other people so you know
this whole analytic versus Continental
thing it's very parochial and it's not
the way that you want to approach things
or think about things
um
all right here's a
a question about uh metal music Galen do
you think ingve Malmsteen is underrated
or doesn't get the amount of popularity
he deserves his Spotify numbers are
comparatively low I have never found
Yngwie Malmsteen or the neoclassical
shredding approach interesting myself
um it's just not something that I
respond to is he underrated I actually
think he's kind of overrated myself but
I wouldn't use Spotify numbers to see
whether somebody's rated or you know
highly or or not because Spotify is just
one of many different streaming services
if you want to know about Yngwie
malmsteen's popularity and Legacy you
got to start long before Spotify or any
streaming service uh came on because
Malmsteen emerged in the 1980s right and
so look at what people were saying about
him in the 1980s in the 1990s in the
early 2000s not just what people are you
know whether they're downloading his
stuff now or not
um so
all right uh
let's see Sans says I've seen people
talk about the contradictions in
Nietzsche's work and whether these
contradictions are intentional or not do
you have any examples of these
contradictions I don't know which
contradictions you're you're bringing up
so I don't
I I wouldn't have examples of what other
people are calling contradictions in
Nature's work but I you know I can think
of some myself
whether they're intentional or not uh
very different topic it's rare that you
find a philosopher who is entirely
consistent across the board where there
won't be any contradictions that you can
find the question isn't really whether
you have contradictions or not it's what
happens with those contradictions and
are they interesting contradictions
um you know Nietzsche if you think about
the the you know status of himself as an
author
um where does he fit into his own
discussions of morality maybe he doesn't
fit quite so well that might be a
contradiction
I've seen people
um foolishly trying to claim that
Nietzsche has cardinal virtues because
there's one passage in uh one text where
he says that these are the four virtues
I think are important but if you
actually read across Nietzsche's Works
he says the virtues contradict each
other right so Nietzsche's not going to
have cardinal virtues even if you know
somebody's uh bad gloss on him says so
um that could be another contradiction
um I mean he he has some I don't know if
you want to call this a contradiction or
not but
if you look at his criticisms of his
first major work the birth of tragedy
out of the spirit of Music he's pretty
hard on it in his preface to it
maybe that's a sign of contradiction but
you know again we got to think about
what kind of contradictions are we we're
talking about here
all right
um
oh juice are you familiar with David
Chalmers if so do you think is standard
for explaining the hard problems of
Consciousness is too high I don't mess
around with Chalmers and I don't you
know I've the little bits that I read I
didn't find interesting enough to follow
up
um so I don't really have much to say
about that
um you probably need to ask somebody who
actually like cares about the guy and it
doesn't it you know whether or not I
like him that doesn't have anything to
say necessarily about whether his work
is good
um for any any you know random
philosopher you pick odds are I haven't
read them because
you know there's like
thousands of philosophers out there and
if you're spending a lot of time reading
Descartes and Heidegger and you know
woolstonecraft you're probably not
spending time reading Chalmers or pick
whoever else you wanted right
um
let's see here Kevin Sanders have you
read any of the resic analytics stuff uh
I'll just stop you right there and say
probably not you know
um who's got the time right uh on the
meaning of life no I I don't read I
don't read much analytic philosophy the
stuff that I do read tends to be going
back to the people who I actually found
interesting or enjoyed you know like uh
John wisdom for example
um I do like to meander around in
Wittgenstein every once in a while
um but I you know there's so much
analytic stuff out there that's
constantly being generated and they're
often just Reinventing wheels that they
they you know somebody else has already
discussed that I just don't find it
worth doing
all right Elijah Miller Blondell
discusses creation of individual
differences and values in La pase volume
two but seems to think some values are
better seems to think it's better to
Value exclusivity in sex what areas of
his work can help one think through what
individual values deviating from the
norm may be personally good what's the
relation for him between the absolute
and individual values I don't know I
mean I haven't looked at La pase for
over a decade so
um
you know I'm not a good one actually to
answer that and unfortunately there
aren't that many blown doll Scholars out
there
uh black prairie this semester in uni
gave me great Intrigue into politics
particularly my countries I don't know
what country that is what philosophical
Works do you recommend for a politics
fledgling I mean there's like a whole
you know generally we call it a canon in
political philosophy that you could read
your way through starting with like
Plato and maybe you actually want to get
comparative with this and read some you
know South Asian and East Asian stuff as
well
Aristotle's politics of course and then
you know I mean there's like hundreds of
books that could carry you all the way
into the 20th century so
I don't think that
you know it's absolutely necessary that
you like begin with the Republic because
that sets the the the
um tone for everything you just read
around you know in stuff that has to do
with political communities and societies
and who should be in charge and you know
um what different kinds of regimes there
are and how they shape people and and
you're going to find all sorts of cool
stuff out there and a lot of it will be
referring back to
earlier thinkers sometimes
appropriatively sometimes critically you
know
all right
um let's see here
to do a lot of back and forth discussion
uh Ben says which philosophers from
history do you feel are most often
misrepresented I mean I'm tempted to say
all of them right again these these are
things where people keep asking these
very very very general questions
um and there aren't great answers to
this because it kind of depends on where
you go right and what what period you're
looking at or whose discussion I mean to
take analytic philosophy right analytic
philosophers typically don't read much
prior to the 20th century right they're
mostly reading other analytic
philosophers and so even if they are
like an analytic tomest or taking an
analytic approach to Descartes they
usually kind of screw it up right and
misrepresent it because they're always
looking for what's the thesis you know
um and so I'd say there's a lot of
people who do that in Continental people
depending on where they're coming from
like the people who are doing
hermeneutics are usually doing better
historical work than people who are like
you know marxists or or
deconstructionists or stuff like that
because they're usually like cherry
picking What will what will
um work with their program whereas
hermeneutics you know which comes out of
phenomenology is trying to figure out
what did the person actually have to say
and is is this true or not are they
making an interesting contribution can
we appropriate this for ourselves so I
mean you could pick just about any
philosopher through history and there's
going to be you know some significant
misrepresentations of them you know just
to take one prime example right Hegel
does like doing things in threes there
is no hegelian dialectic that is thesis
antithesis synthesis and anybody who
tells you that there is is either
misinformed or just stupid or a grifter
who's trying to use it for their own
purposes
um and that's a misrepresentation and
and you can find that in you know what
should be reliable histories of
philosophy like William Durant's the
story of philosophy but
um the better store the history is a
philosophy don't do that read Friedrich
hobbleston in his discussion of hegelian
dialectic and the you know thesis
antithesis synthesis and we could just
you know
go and
find you know dozens of philosophers
who've been misrepresented that way
right
um
where I start have you read any Simone
Vey and or Martin boober yeah I've read
both of them neither of them are
particularly important to my work uh and
um you know I'll probably never do
anything on vague because there's other
people doing decent work out there I
might someday incorporate Uber into my
the existentialism class that I teach
and then that means I would shoot some
videos on him but you know I he's not
somebody who I I read very much you know
uh saying what do you think of our
faculty professors who make us memorize
philosophical Concepts without ever
applying them anywhere
that's an unfortunate way of teaching
philosophy I do see a lot of people
doing that approach
um
more so in uh non-american a
non-canadian context where there does at
least seem to be some
emphasis on what would we actually do
with this unless on rote memorization
but um
yeah I mean that's that's sort of a
it's sort of a way to teach people
what's not Philosophy by the way the
same thing doesn't work for History
either you know history is not just
memorizing dates and
you know points you you need to like
think about greater uh issues like well
what's actually going on here what's the
mechanism of causality if there is any
what is the meaning for for people
involved in it and then you know does
this have any lessons for us in our own
presence and we can say similar things
about philosophy right
uh Bruno says uh are you familiar with
Tron do you enjoy his work I've only
read glosses on him I haven't actually
read him but he is somebody who I do
have on the list to go to
um because uh you know it seems like
somebody who's drawing on other
philosophers that I'm interested in and
he is considered an existentialist so I
probably should you know incorporate uh
him into
my my sequence of videos on that
all right
um
Ty says have you read any of the work uh
connecting to a greater degree McIntyre
and radical aristotelianism back to
Marxism like Paul black black ledge and
Calvin Knight and so do you have any
thoughts on that I mean I've sat and
drank beers and chatted with Calvin
Knight
at the international Society for
McIntyre in inquiry the last one I was
at was actually uh about 11 years ago in
Grand Rapids Michigan and so yeah I'm
pretty familiar with that and I I think
that it's basically right
you know McIntyre is a great critical
synthesizer and Marxism was you know
part of his formation and it's never
gone away it's always it's always been
there and
um radical aristotelianism is a great
way of describing how we should apply
virtue ethics in the present you know
um we should we should take and you see
McIntyre doing this it's not just with
marks it's with
you know utilitarianism and John Stuart
Mill he also does this with Kant he'll
say hey these people have something
useful to contribute let's take it on
and like the Borg assimilated he doesn't
he doesn't liken himself to the Borg but
in some respects uh McIntyre and
Aristotelian virtue ethics has a
borg-like element to it right so yeah
I'm I'm uh I'm quite interested in that
approach
um and there's many others who've been
doing this for for quite a long time
right
um mondavarius do you have a favorite
work of Hemingway it's been a long time
since I've read them
okay
and I can't claim that I've like read
all of Hemingway's works
we we read
um The Sun Also Rises back when I was in
college as part of our honors sequence
and I I enjoyed reading Hemingway we
also had to read the old man in the sea
when I was in high school and I I found
that really great
um I don't know if I went back to it and
if today I would I would have the same
thing
um you know I read For Whom the Bell
Tolls for a history class and and wrote
about that and of course if you're
teaching existentialism you typically
reference a clean well-lighted place
which I have read recently that's a
short story
um but you know I'm I'm somebody who can
appreciate Hemingway but he's not like
up there in my my favorite authors and I
haven't gone back to him other than a
queen clean well-lighted place for a
long time so
um
oh I skipped over somebody personal
shopper are you familiar with the work
of Andreas malm never heard of him so
can't even say anything about that but
then again you know there's like
thousands of people I've never heard of
they're they're you know tens of
thousands of people publishing books in
philosophy every year so you know odds
are most of us aren't going to have
encountered most other people in the
business you could say
uh Daniel I've been reading a lot on the
right that there's a gnostic conspiracy
against the western civilization I want
to study this right new right-wing
discourse but do you think it's relevant
yeah it's relevant in the sense that you
do want to like read The Crazies of your
time so that you can understand what
sort of they're trying to sell
you
you know
um
it's sort of like reading Hitler's mind
comp right if you were in 1939
um you know the Nazis were pretty
disgusting individuals and if you've
ever read mind comp which I I have you
know it's it's coherent in places but
it's all ultimately the work of uh you
know very bitter deranged uh you know
cobbler together of ideas
um and a lot of the stuff coming out of
the right today is like that no big
surprise it's not as if the character of
whack jobs uh has changed over time you
know
um it's just that they've got bigger
pulpits now that they've got all these
great you know internet uh
uh technologies that they can draw upon
but I mean anybody who's like throwing
around terms like Gnostic is probably
full of crap you know here'd be an
example of somebody who's not that way
but is been dead for a long time Hans
Jonas great you know uh German
philosopher student of Heidegger
um
the Gnostic religion where he actually
like looks at you know the Gnostic
religions what we can say about them and
kind of a
careful coherent way and then talks
about the Contemporary situation that he
sees in in the West in his time and it's
good to read the things like that too
because you'll see that a lot of what is
being generated on the right is just
regurgitated you know sort of
like in the analytic philosophy
Reinventing wheels that like
better philosophers than them you know
went over maybe in ancient times maybe
in early modern times that's what's
happening a lot on the right you know is
just you know reworking of old stuff but
adding a few new twists to it you know
but it's basically the same old song and
dance so to speak so I mean if you want
to spend time on it sure go ahead
um you could actually ask yourself with
every like blog post or video or
something like that is it really is this
a great use of my time or should I be
rereading Descartes you know
um or Piqua or Aleister McIntyre for
that matter who also sees this stuff as
silly nonsense if you ever want to see
something kind of interesting Google
McIntyre Benedict option maybe like
critique or speech and you will see him
tearing into Rod drayer's misuse of mac
and tires phrase about you know needing
a new Saint Benedict and saying this is
this totally misrepresents my position
and my work this person doesn't know
what the hell they're doing so
all right um
all right so shalu says I'm going
through a crisis after losing somebody
to Suicide the guilt and confusion is
actually making me paralyzed to maintain
my reading interests what text can I
read in this regard well I mean if
you're having trouble reading I don't
know that you can read a text that will
make you able to read I think what you
need to do is is uh think about why
there's guilt uh involved on your part
and whether the guilt is legitimate or
misplaced or stuff like that right
um
and you know why why you are confused
about this person killing themselves I
mean people have been doing that
um throughout all time and there's not
one single reason why why people take
their own life or attempt to take their
own life
um I mean there are there are
discussions about it I I would actually
stay away from discussions about the
rightness or wrongness of suicide like
you know what the stoics think about it
that's probably not going to be very
helpful for you I would actually
probably not not read an awful lot about
suicide but think about what else you
can read that is life affirming and
isn't about or isn't connected to the
person who you've lost
like you could read rilka's poems
and think about the Wonders and beauty
of the world that we still inhabit uh
even after somebody is gone you know
um maybe that would be helpful
um
but I mean there aren't there aren't a
lot of other things I think I could say
about that
um
all right Josh says if I ever want to go
to graduate school to specialize in
Hegel do I necessarily have to apply to
a program where there are Hegel Scholars
if not what are some of your suggestions
so my suggestion is don't go to a
graduate school to specialize in Hegel
um that I've seen a lot of people who do
go to graduate school and they're like I
know what my research project is and the
right answer to that from your advisor
is you don't know a damn thing you just
have some feelings right now about what
it would be cool for you to do but you
go to graduate school to learn a lot
across a wide range of you know and then
figure out later on years in what you
want to specialize in
um I've seen so many people make
mistakes that way saying oh I've got to
go and you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
specialize in Aristotle in The Logical
work so I better go to Emory and study
with this person and they get there and
they're really unhappy or they find out
that that person who they are going to
Hitch their wagon to their star so to
speak is about to retire or has in bad
health or is going through a divorce or
is gonna leave for another institution
you know
um
I don't think that's a good way to to
set yourself up for graduate school at
all I think what you want to do is be
open to learning about a variety of
different uh
thinkers tax movements you know and then
make a decision later on I mean I went
to graduate school thinking I was going
to do philosophy of language and then
um ended up you know
doing my Master's thesis on on horse's
role in the past of synthesis lectures
and then
um deciding you know I was going to like
probably do my dissertation on Dairy dog
getting talked out of that rightly so by
uh one of one of our people and then
thinking I was going to do a
dissertation on Hegel and Blondell and
eventually just switching to just
blownell you know and then after that
um
doing other kinds of work including on
ansom and Aristotle and Thomas Hobbs you
know so I wouldn't
think of specializing that that early
right
all right
um
let's see here vegan sports bar do you
know if Nietzsche ever gave criticism to
shopping hours the wisdom of Life uh
directly I don't know
um I mean he certainly is is critical of
schopenhauer on a lot of points for
being unduly pessimistic and life
denying and stuff like that right
um
Albert says as far as I can see there
isn't a some single type of crazy
regardless of left or right to suggest
otherwise would be delude oneself in
partisan thinking yeah pretty irrelevant
I would say yeah of course there isn't a
single type of crazy but let's not do
both both sides-isms uh clearly at this
point in history there are way more
crazy nut jobs at least here in America
on the right than there are on the left
and they they're not all one pathology
obviously but you know that's that's
kind of
kind of the situation right now
um reflective journey I definitely agree
Gnostic Pagan was Christian vocabulary
to other eyes there is no content there
no that's not true
um and you should get rid of that idea
there there were in fact gnostics and it
wasn't just about other rising and as a
matter of fact there are even some
Orthodox who use the word gnosis like
Clement of Alexandria the I'd keep your
hands off the ancient stuff right until
you've actually like got a a solid take
on the complexities of what was going on
at the time over those you know several
hundred years but yes in the present it
is used basically to put things into
boxes in a neat way that allows them to
have a program about stuff
um
all right Syed do you think Heidegger's
concept of nothing Bears any
correspondence to Descartes concept of
nothingness I read something about it
but I don't know if there's any stock in
this comparison don't make comparisons
um read the Heidegger and
um you know think about the fact that
Heidegger's
um great essay which is what I use to
introduce Heidegger what is metaphysics
which talks about the nothing has an
entire discussion about previous
approaches to the nothing now he's not
mentioning Descartes as such there but
Heidegger talks about Descartes quite a
bit in his Works
Descartes doesn't thematize the nothing
in the way that Heidegger does Descartes
talks about for example uh us being in
between God and uh nothingness Neons
right but Descartes is never going to
say la neon the nothing you know and and
say let me explore this the way that
Heidegger is doing or sorry is doing
later on right
um so you can certainly draw connections
between them I wouldn't worry about
trying to compare them because Heidegger
is already
saying my conception is going beyond
what other people who obviously have
talked about the nothing or about
non-being or stuff like that in the past
what they have to offer I'm I'm giving
you something that's a little bit more I
mean and we can also if we want to talk
about the nothing or non-being or stuff
like that and some talks about
nothingness right the the knee hill
um in in his Works
um
Aristotle and Plato are both concerned
about non-being and and what its status
is so yeah
yeah all right uh Dr Beavis I'm happy to
see this live once again cheers football
as well yeah we do this every every
month first Saturday you know same same
time I got kind of a regular thing going
oh to loose uh great advice about grad
school I have several friends currently
in grad school they've all changed their
focus on the fields more than once yeah
I mean to go back to that it would be
weird if you didn't change because that
would mean that you really didn't learn
anything except in the narrow area that
you picked and I'm not saying this
necessarily holds for all graduate or
professional schools but certainly for
philosophy you know I mean if you go to
a good grad school you should get
introduced to a bunch of texts and
thinkers and approaches that you didn't
get or you only got a little smattering
of in your undergraduate otherwise
you're kind of wasting your money and
your time right the whole point of going
to graduate school is to expand your
horizons and learn how to do research
better
and improve your writing skills and
thinking skills and widen your your um
your mental map that you're making of
the discipline right those are all
things that kind of go against
um hyper specialization you know
Michael says thank you so much for your
speculative fiction series I plan on
reading the greens Earthsea series to my
newborn daughter eventually is there
anything else that you can recommend for
young adults
um
well I mean young adults newborns two
different things
um
let's split the difference and just talk
about children right so if we're
thinking about speculative fiction
series there are some that are written
for younger people you know C.S Lewis's
Chronicles of Narnia is is pretty cool
um obviously Madeleine langel's time
quintet you know really great stuff
um
Lloyd Alexander I very much loved the
chronicles of pritian when I was a kid
and then the captain Kestrel stories I I
don't know I haven't read those lately
but I'm assuming they probably hold up
pretty decently
um
but you know like leguin herself
observes
books
can be written for adults and also very
suitable for children you might have to
do some explaining or some pausing and
saying uh here's here's what's actually
happening here especially when it comes
to things that they don't they don't
quite understand right
[Music]
um
so
yeah I mean who else would be good
um
I mean The Hobbit right
um Lord of the Rings might be a little
dense
for later on
um
who else would be good you know
maybe Andrew Norton I think she's very
readable you know
but all right so let's let's uh go on
um
so Mark says it's amazing how a Centrist
nuanced view is hated by the both left
and right equally
left-wing crazies are just a slightly
newer breed of crazies
yeah that's exactly what a Centrist
would say a self-proclaimed Centrist uh
and there's a good uh thing here from
black prairie would it be inaccurate to
say most centrists are actually just
reactionaries not reactionaries
um sometimes split the differences sort
of people sometimes cowards sometimes
you know needing to like Place
themselves above everybody else I have
been very unimpressed with people who
call themselves centrists
um
for at least you know a decade or so I
think you know and I've kind of moved
around you could say I've I'm I'm a
Critic of where I see criticism is
necessary because I'm a virtue at the
system not a hell of a lot of virtue in
most centrists I gotta say so
all right
um
let's see here
Dr Beavis is there a philosopher you
think is really shot out as in a radical
new thought that hasn't been already
talked about
uh I don't know the the locution shot
out in this sense but we'll go with this
uh having a radical new thought that
hasn't already been talked about yeah I
mean this happens all the time
throughout history right to go back to
the original question that we were being
asked about you know what what could
Plato have written dialogues about that
he didn't that would have liked to have
seen uh you know the issues of freedom
and determinism people come up with new
ideas
and so you see you know like Plato not
really worrying about that Aristotle
kind of thinking about that a bit but
not too much mostly thinking about the
voluntary and the involuntary and then
it becomes like a big issue
with the epicureans and stoics and and
later you know eclectic writers like
Cicero and
um then we get you know aristotelians
like Alexander of aphrodisias taking up
the question and writing a book like on
fate you know there's all sorts of
interesting things or something new
comes in and we don't need it to be
radically new we just need it to be
let's say sufficiently new right and
that is enough there's I think sometimes
way too much emphasis on novelty on
originality you know anytime that you
come up with a cool new idea
it's going to have Roots you know it's
not just going to be oh I came up with
an idea in the you know uh while I was
on my own or you know in the bathtub or
something like that there's gonna be you
know a whole bunch of Preparatory stuff
and then somebody comes up with a new
idea and you know part of this happens
because we're we're dealing with new
situations so if you think about what
we're doing here right now you know
using this this technology in a very
complex mediated way to have a
philosophical discussion that's not
something that's a Heidegger thought
about or Descartes thought about or Mary
Wollstonecraft thought about or
Aristotle thought about they could
contribute you know a few
interesting insights
um but other people have to come around
and and conceptualize that to go back to
the Marlow Ponte thing he draws on all
these people
talking about
um
the effects of of you know head injuries
largely due to shrapnel from artillery
in World War One and the observations
that can come about because of that uh
give mariloponte some new gripping
points to think about stuff so you know
um
all right let's see
Josh says I only minored in philosophy I
haven't written any papers I was happy
with I applied for grad school is it a
good idea to write something new or
should I rewrite something I've got you
could do either I mean it depends on
what your papers look like I I don't
know what the quality of your papers
um you're talking about the writing
sample for for graduate school I would
be more worried about your cover letter
which is going to have to make the case
that even though you don't have a degree
in philosophy
um you are still a good candidate for
graduate school and I would be prepared
for if they do admit you and only
certain programs will admit somebody who
either has a different degree or you
know has a minor you're going to have to
do some remedial coursework
um taking like 400 level classes most
likely that's usually the way I mean
that's American University I can't talk
about other places but
all right uh lapse nine Continuum does
Hegel ever discuss any of the American
founding fathers wonder what he would
have thought of somebody like Thomas
Jefferson that's a good question I don't
remember specific discussion of founding
fathers who I think are highly overrated
anyway we have this kind of silly
mythology about them
um some of them were interesting people
some of them were you know just complete
scumbags
um we don't have to be beholden to their
ideas in a you know very changed uh
Republic you know
representative democracy what we have of
it
um but I mean Hegel
seems to trade from what I recall
America is kind of like this well we
don't know what's going to happen with
with these people but he's mostly
concerned with what's going on
in Western Europe I mean he doesn't even
really care that much about
um southern Europe or Eastern Europe
even so
all right
um black prairie I'm currently doing a
tabletop campaign centered on politics
tips to get my apolitical friends into a
political dilemma
well I don't know that's a good question
I mean maybe think about the real
foundational questions in politics that
I mentioned earlier like who should be
in charge and why
or how here's a perennial problem how do
we pass on
um Power in a way that is legitimating
to the new regime
and preserves continuity at the same
time you know
um which which institutions
ought to be
valued and which ones you know what do
we do in the case of corruption which is
always a problem you know do we scour
The Stables so to speak or do we take a
much more nuanced approach
um
mondavarius
uh any our kierkegaard's thoughts still
relevant today well I mean the simple
question or simple answer is read and
find out right
um and if you do you will find some
thoughts that are relevant today
Heidegger Kierkegaard rather is thinking
about the individual within what's
slowly becoming a mass Society you know
structured by what he calls leveling and
um you know trying to make sense out of
the Absurd I think a lot of character
guards ideas can be quite useful
um depending on what you want to do with
them I will say that when I was a
undergraduate I didn't have other than
the crowd is untruth and the present age
I didn't have much use for Kierkegaard
he was a little bit too religious for me
you know but as I got older and I could
see you know a greater scope to his
stuff and understand him better I found
quite a few of his ideas interesting and
he's also you know somebody who winds up
being uh reinterpreted by other later
thinkers as well like Miguel de unumuno
or you know Martin Heidegger or
um you know people much closer to the
present as well like derida for example
he's got a whole book on on uh
Kierkegaard
from the 90s
uh Mark says variant on desert island
question what five books would you want
to stick in a time capsule for future
generations to dig up text worth
preserving and why it's always tough to
pick those isn't it because there's
um
so many
books that we'd like to get in there and
when we have to restrict it to five you
know it's tempting to say well an
anthology right something that's got
like uh
1200 Pages you know
um
but if we had to pick like actual
individual works
um
Time Capsule for future generations to
dig up
so I think we would probably want to
reject
things that are like you know currently
New York Times bestsellers that are
discussing our current culture because
usually those wind up being superficial
and and as it turns out over time wrong
you know or or big picture you know
books about the human race you know we
probably wouldn't want that stuff either
[Music]
um
and we wouldn't want it just to be just
philosophy books right we would want
stuff that's broadly representative that
could give a person
from
you know 200 years in the future an idea
about what we were thinking about now
and maybe
so I'm going to cheat a little bit maybe
what we'd do is pick some speculative
fiction
that really does have you know
a grasp on where things are
so you know what we did recently
um Kim Stanley Robinson's Mars trilogy
there's a lot of really interesting
thought built into it and he considers
it one single novel spanning 1700 Pages
we can say a similar thing about Dan
Simmons Hyperion cantos he actually says
it's two novels uh both of which happen
to be two books long
um maybe we want stuff like that you
know to go forward and they could be
like oh yeah they were right about this
with the AIS and they're wrong about
this you know but we'd want stuff that
has some real meat to it
um and is is Well written so that I
think that's about as far as I can get
with with this
um
Armin his most analytic philosophy
Linguistics sophistry no and it's it's
not very helpful to say stuff like that
I mean
if that's your point of view you
probably want to reconsider that
language sophistry is a very strong
accusation it means essentially just
playing around with language in ways
that are manipulative trying to confuse
people and all that and you know to
attribute that to most analytic
philosophy I think it's it's just silly
you know you could say that a lot of it
is um like I said Reinventing wheels
that it would have been better to like
go back to the the earlier literature or
that some of it is
perhaps you know um like a lot of other
philosophy not not really well thought
out or well written but I wouldn't call
it sophistry that's that's just sort of
like trying to stir up you know
that's like when the analytics will will
use the same word about Continental
philosophy people probably need to back
off about that kind of stuff you know
it's not you got to ask yourself what's
the point in labeling it something like
that
does it make you feel good
um doesn't Advance anything right
all right
um
reflective Journey Discovery invention
Duality starts to break down if you
essentialize it I don't know it
essentialize it would mean
um but you know I'll just put it to you
this way the Latin word that we
translate as either an invention or
Discovery inventory or invincio means
both
you know so people have known for a very
long time that
um it's not as if there's a hard line
between Discovery and invention
um Michelangelo should the preface to
the phenomenology of spirit be read
before or after one has read the entire
book yes both
um it's uh people have all sorts of
opinions about how you're supposed to
read Hegel
um and I think a lot of them are just
kind of full of you know
um try to read the preface if if it
doesn't make sense to you just move on
you know read the introduction then and
go into the other stuff and obviously
you're gonna have to read the text more
than once so you're going to read the
preface again the next time you you read
it and there's nothing that says that
you can't like read a section and come
back to a previous section and re-read
it as a matter of fact you probably
should be doing that because in the
phenomenology Hegel later on will say
hey remember when I said blah blah blah
you know that's what I hear now we're
actually seeing what that means so you
got to go back and see what blah blah
blah he said right so
um
you know you can do it whatever way you
want to
all right uh Ben says as a young person
wanting to do a degree in philosophy is
there any subject matter of philosophers
you think would be beneficial to look
into
yeah I mean I would I would uh spend
time reading the people that we you know
consider classic and put in the Canon
because any good program that you're
going to be in you're going to be
encountering them again and it sure
won't hurt you to have read some Plato
or some Descartes or some Nietzsche
before getting into a class where you're
going to reread it or perhaps read new
stuff by it and get new takes on it and
discuss it again an interesting ways you
know
um
reflective journey I really like the
hermeneutical way to view past figures
are there any good reasons against that
um I mean people bring up all sorts of
reasons about thinking about the past
like you know some people say well
there's real philosophy in them there's
the history of philosophy which I think
is kind of stupid
um when you when you actually think it
through and and look at what the history
of philosophy provides us with and
there's multiple ways to do history of
philosophy as well
um
I mean people come up with all sorts of
reasons like oh it's a waste of time but
how do you know that you're how do you
know it's a waste of time unless you
actually spend some time on it some
Professor saying that you shouldn't just
like accept that on on faith right so
you know there's reasons whether they're
good reasons or not I think depends kind
of on where you sit right
all right
um
oh to loose what do you think that
ancient stoics would think about the
modern colloquial usage of the word
stoic
um there are there are multiple modern
colloquial usages of the word stoic and
within the modern stoic Community for
years and years we have been
um distinguishing between stoic
lowercase s just meaning like stiff
upper lip and unemotional and
um
you know stoic uppercase s meaning the
actual philosophy and uh that
distinction wasn't there in epictetus's
time but if you actually read Epictetus
you will find him criticizing people who
call themselves stoics who aren't really
stoics and who have picked up on some of
the doctrine
and gotten other parts wrong so for
example uh Epictetus will say explicitly
that
um it's not rational that is not stoic
to Simply make up your mind about
something and then stick to it
resolutely if you if you pick the wrong
thing like I should starve myself to
death as he's talking to one of his
friends in the discourses so it's not as
if this is radically new
um they knew that people could
misappropriate stoicism in their time
and they talk about it sometimes right
Epictetus probably more than anybody
else although Seneca sometimes will say
yeah this is a misunderstanding or I
disagree with my fellow stoics about
about this matter over over here
um I will say there's a lot of people
because of the popularity of stoicism
who throw the word around who don't know
much about stoicism who get it wrong in
important respect or who are just using
it to grift and make money and attain
what the stoics is called indifference
money Prestige social status stuff like
that right but I don't think that would
have been a huge surprise to any of them
because they knew that people have a
tendency to that right
[Music]
um
columus uh slightly strange question do
you think there are things that require
us to appeal to a power outside our to a
power ourselves
I'm not sure what that actually means
things that require us to appeal to a
power is that outside of ourselves or in
ourselves or
a power that is us
I I don't really know
maybe you can clarify what you mean
there uh lamps oh outside of ourselves
well we encounter Powers outside of
ourselves all the time uh you know for
example the sun that's casting light
here that's a power outside of ourself
now appeal to you know do you mean for
as an explanatory Principle as in
something that we rely upon where again
we we live in what I view as a
pluralistic Universe where there are
many different things that are outside
of ourselves and that we interact with
so it's almost trivially true right uh
lapse nine Continuum uh thoughts on Noam
Chomsky I don't really care about
Chomsky I find his linguistic work kind
of implausible
um I don't really care that much about
him as a a political
figure
so I've never I've never taken him
really that seriously myself but he's
very popular isn't he you know lots of
people like like the guy
um Alex Hoffman don't have a question
just wanted to say I enjoy your work
glad glad you do mondavarius do you have
a work of Plato that you least prefer
no I I don't have anything where I'm I
guess maybe I do have to take that back
there is that one uh thing that's
basically just a a speech and I'm
blanking in on the name it's supposed to
be sort of like a parody of the Pericles
funeral oration and I I don't go back to
that but I mean the rest of the stuff I
think is you know there's some dialogues
I I'm more interested in than others but
it's not like I I look at one I'm like
oh that dialogue again I hate that crap
you know so
all right
um
John Garrell how do you feel about
Marx's take on hegel's dialectics I
don't have any feelings about Marx's
take on hegel's dialectics because I'm
not sure what your what you actually
mean do you mean like what Marx and
marxists have done with what they take
to be hegel's dialectics the synthesis
or thesis antithesis synthesis thing
which is not actually Hegel
um
I mean I think that uh there's different
kinds of dialectics the word has been
around since the time of Plato and it
means a whole bunch of different things
right and so we it's not as if there's
any one single dialectic right Thomas uh
says
do you ever consider going to law school
or do you have any advice for philosophy
ba in relation to pursuing a legal
career well the advice is yes go to law
school right and uh you know if you want
to practice law then then find a good
law school and and uh apply and go to it
and you know there's different ways of
preparing for the lsats and all of that
I actually did consider going to law
school so actually this is kind of an
interesting story so my my dad as many
of you know
My adoptive dad uh Tony Sadler he was a
tax attorney and that meant that he had
um earned his law degree from University
of Wisconsin-Madison really good school
and it also
um he also had a CPA so he had sort of a
double professional thing and
unfortunately he died
um quite young he was only 36 years old
and then you know my family went through
all sorts of troubles and turmoils I
didn't plan even going to college I was
just going to go in the military and
that isn't in fact what I did
and
um when I got out I decided to go to
college and I'd actually taken my SATs
in the military because they wanted me
to go they wanted to put me in this
office or training school where I would
go from like a basic and AIT into this
this Officer school and then I got in a
fight in the barracks and that was the
end of that that program for me but I've
still taken the SAT so I went and uh you
know went to school majored in
philosophy and Mathematics and then I I
finished
and then my mom was like I want you to
go to law school
and I will pay for the whole thing and
it was it was a legacy thing she
she felt like this would be a way for me
to follow in my my dad's footsteps
and at that time I wasn't interested in
the idea I actually took a year off and
just worked as a security guard and
Barista and studied languages and
exercised and you know
partied a bit and you know you know I
had a girlfriend uh actually a couple of
girlfriends during that time and then I
traveled a bit and then I went to
graduate school for philosophy
and while I was at Southern Illinois
Carbondale I could have gone to law
school
in that time my mother died I had you
know a small inheritance and if I'd
wanted to stay in Carbondale I could
have gone to SIU law school after I
finished my PhD but I wanted to get the
hell out of there and like get get on
with my life and so then we moved to
Northwestern Indiana and then I started
reconsidering and I was like you know
I'm getting more and more interested in
law and legal philosophy and stuff like
that it would be kind of cool to to get
a law degree and then I looked into what
would be you know needed for that and
um
you know I could go to Valparaiso which
was like ranked about as low as you
could possibly go just the bottom of the
barrel for law schools or I could drive
up to Chicago or I could drive down to
Indianapolis and there weren't any like
distance things at the time so I was
like yeah that's not feasible I've got
kids I've got a job you know uh this
just isn't gonna happen so I I just
wrote it off and at this point in time I
don't think I would be interested in
going to law school you know I'm happy
with the kind of stuff that I do already
you know I got another maybe 30 years if
I'm lucky so I don't want to uh
spend it going to law school but it's
kind of a cool idea you know
all right
um
Zach says
uh
uh any thoughts on topics of animal
ethics or the philosophy of animal
Consciousness yeah I'm always it's kind
of weird to see people talking about
animals not being sentient given that in
ancient
uh medieval and modern times it was
taken for granted that animals are
sentient right uh Century means to be
able to sense and nowadays we have a
kind of weird use of it among the people
that are doing this kind of stuff that's
very counter-intuitive you know
um
I mean I it seems obvious to me that
animals have Consciousness they just
have different kinds of Consciousness
than we do you know
um
and I don't think that they're just meat
machines like Descartes portrays them as
so
um animal ethics I mean there's a lot
involved in that depends on what you're
asking about so
all right uh reflective journey I
recently read Lloyd garson's from Plato
to platonism some really interesting
insights that I think is ur platonism is
perhaps too General would love to know
your thoughts haven't read the book so
how I'm you know how am I going to
respond to that
um
I think I've read bits and pieces if
we're thinking about an older book I've
read bits and pieces if we're thinking
about his newest book I haven't read it
Mark any horror films you enjoy and by
enjoy I mean scared you shirtless maybe
sci-fi horror
so scary scary uh
um
horror Prince of Darkness is still
creepy as hell today
I mean it was I think it was done in the
mid 80s
um and I saw it for the first time I was
probably like 89 90.
and wow was that
scary
uh Event Horizon pretty scary you know
and there we've got like uh you know
sci-fi horror
um
trying to think of what else I've seen I
haven't seen a lot of horror movies
lately
um
so I'm gonna have to take a pass on the
rest of that
um
in the chilled aisle I think you're cool
and I've admired your work for years
keep it up dude I will hopefully you
know I mean uh fate willing uh hopefully
I don't get like sick or anything like
that but if I don't I'll just keep
grinding away and doing more of it uh
Armin is math of science depends on what
you mean by science right there isn't
any like one single agreed upon
definition that everybody has a
consensus on we can certainly say that
mathematics is rigorous right
and that it's uh absolutely essential to
a lot of the other Sciences
um but it depends on what you mean by a
science right
drowning in decimals any thoughts on AI
disruption to your pedagogy AI can't
really disrupt my pedagogy you know
that's the thing when you're doing like
real education
not just chick tick ticking boxes or
allowing people to
um
do the kind of stuff that's easy to
cheat on uh AI isn't very useful you
know and as a matter of fact I will say
this too I'm going to be incorporating
some modules on AI specifically on chat
GPT into
um
some of the stuff that I'm doing at
Milwaukee Institute of Art design where
we're actually going to like use it and
then critically look at its results I
mean AI tends to make make stuff up it
draws connections that are out there
through its machine learning and machine
learning isn't real learning artificial
intelligence isn't real intelligence
these are just metaphors that we use
they're complex processes that that are
done algorithmically using vast data
sets but oftentimes you know generating
kind of goofy results so we want the
students to see that these goofy results
are not things that we need to
incorporate or rely upon right
all right uh Dr Beavis if you could
encapsulate Philip K dick in one
sentence what would it be I mean I
wouldn't even try
uh so I don't I don't think those those
sorts of things are useful Mark Lane
brings up a good other scary movie
Hellraiser it's been a long long time
since I've seen it
um you know actually that reminds me of
another scary one Candyman that that was
scary when I saw that too uh I don't
know if the sequels were as good but
worth checking out
English gal have you studied loving us I
haven't did studied loving us in fact I
studied with somebody who translated
lavinas
who worked closely with Alfonso Lingus
until the two of them broke and then he
uh took his name off the translation he
was working on
um so yeah I've I've read plenty of
loving ass in the past living ass is
kind of a big deal back in the 90s when
I was in grad school
uh mandavarius did you start Philosophy
by reading the earliest works or did you
already have a philosopher you enjoyed
and started from there neither the first
philosophical work I think that I read
was uh Albert Camus the myth of Sisyphus
I I don't think I understood more than
one-tenth of what I was reading and I
wasn't reading it because I wanted to
read philosophy I thought Greek
mythology was cool and I thought it was
going to be a book about Greek mythology
so
um and then you know I just kind of you
know I got introduced to things here and
there I wrote an article recently uh the
tale of two philosophy teachers that you
can look up
talks about my experience with taking a
a philosophy class in high school which
sucked a philosophy class that wasn't a
philosophy class in high school that was
awesome and who these teachers were and
who they introduced us to
um so
all right uh Jay Doug what do you think
of pure macaries point that Hagel and
spinos are oppositional thinkers and one
has to choose its Camp I don't know I've
never heard of this guy and that sounds
kind of like nonsense to me
um I'm sure there's probably
some framework that this guy creates in
which that makes sense but on its
surface just expressed like that I mean
why would you have to be a hegelian or a
spinosist you know why couldn't you be a
delusion why couldn't you be a Cartesian
why couldn't you be you know an
Aristotelian it seems like there's a lot
of other possible options out there you
know so I don't know where this guy is
coming up with this uh
required take a stand from
uh so for the first time it looks like
I've actually run through all the
questions that people are answering as
we're getting to the end of our time so
unless anybody has any well here's
another we got another question already
what are your thoughts on Alfred North
Whitehead I like Whitehead
um
I first read process in reality and
again I can't say that I like totally
understood it I probably understood like
20 of what I was reading you know
um
foreign
when I read that back as an undergrad
and I've read it since and I I like I
like Whitehead so there's process in
reality which is the magnum opus which
is really quite cool
and then there's like you know all these
other works that he writes and sometimes
he's kind of off base and sometimes he's
he's on point you know so he's well he's
well worth reading and I think a lot of
people don't read him today
um or if they do they read them through
the lens of other more contemporary
people like you know the
um movement that was taking off in the
early 2000s with the object oriented
ontology and stuff like that
but I think white is worth reading for
for his own sake
uh lampstein Continuum have you ever
checked out Hubert dreyfus's lectures on
Heidegger yeah but I'm I'm not a big fan
of Dreyfus I I prefer just to read
Heidegger as Heidegger you know there's
such a huge Corpus of his works
I'm I'm not usually that into like
seeing what other people have to say
about you know thinkers I like to read
the thinkers themselves
so all right well it looks like uh we
are
at the not the top of the hour the
middle of the hour I got another event
to do in about half an hour and I got to
get some lunch so
um nobody else has any questions I'm
gonna call it a day for at least for
this got a lot of other stuff to do
today
and I will see you all uh at you know
one of the other many other events we've
got coming up or maybe even uh if you
show up here in Milwaukee face to face
so I'll see all of you later and uh
That's all folks